do they think you're cool you know I
hope shoo I mean I don't know I I think
my boy is oh I think they'll start to
understand you know my oldest - for sure
you know they're just an age but I
didn't know what I do and that's what
eyes my kids my younger - they think
it's really cool
great story and the card all up there
this will answer your question I'm in
the cuddle up there and edge healing
comes on the radio and a great song
called gogo week it'll be Irish song and
I'm just singing away and I'm having a
great time and one of my boys I hate
that see what this is saying is us I
said Ed Sheeran it was exactly what what
I'm saying you know so and then and then
and then so he says that and then while
younger is going whoa
well you get exactly you get roasted you
and I'm you know so i cool I don't know
yeah
[Music]
you're fortunate as an artist in 2017
where you are no longer confined to a
genre yes people in a music organization
the people around you would make sure
you stayed in your lane you're free to
sort of float back and forth now in the
world that we're at yeah I mean I would
feel that yes of and to be honest I
cannot always feel like that you know
I've always allowed other people to
determine what I mean to them so I've
never called myself anything I'm sort of
just allowed people to freedom to
associate me with whatever makes them
feel comfortable yeah you know I've
always sort of just written this song
I've always written songs away the way I
wanted a pleasure I've recorded them the
way that I want to record them
and I've I've sort of presented myself
the way I always see myself which is I'm
really just a blue-collar soul Shanga
really I mean I just sort of sang about
real things and real people
[Music]
did you go into revival with an idea
with the concept I really did it we had
a clear vision for this record I really
wanted to approach the record look the
usually approach records in the old days
you know when I was going on you know
well you would get a bunch of really
talented people you would put them in a
room with a bunch of great songs and
he'd make a record so that's what we did
I knew the colors that I wanted to use
yeah I just have to figure that out I
was going to pay the petrol away and
that's what that's what revival and
again
[Music]